hi this is jelani williams from cmu here
to talk about some joint work that i did
with my advisor wayne wong and professor
anupam gupta
that'll be appearing in itcs 2022
we call it probing to minimize
and so the first thing you might be
asking is you know
what is
probing
and to kind of help elucidate that i'm
going to talk about like a few specific
examples
of probing the the most basic
the most basic concept that defines
probing is that there's some randomness
in the world that you have to interact
with in order to
in order to find out what its value is
so the first example we're going to do
is home renovations
right
when you're
trying to get your home renovated you
have to call up contractors but you
don't have an infinite amount of time to
call up these contractors
right
so
when you call them you have to be
judicious about who you're calling
and say you're trying to like minimize
the
final
cost you end up paying well
when you when you're calling off these
contractors you should be you have to
make some decisions about who you're
calling if you want to minimize that
final quote
the second example we'll go with is
vaccine research funding if you're a
government who's trying to get a
vaccine as soon as possible
then
then you need to
decide
how to distribute your funding in a way
that that accomplishes that right some
scientists might
put forth proposals for sort of riskier
options
when it comes to
like vaccine research right and some
might go for sort of more tried and true
methods
and by by getting the right balance of
them you
can minimize the amount of time it takes
for you to get a viable vaccine
and the third example we'll do is a
record collector say you want to get the
most pristine version of a vinyl record
uh
of a specific vinyl record as possible
and so you you'll run around all these
record stores
uh but they they don't let you actually
see the condition of the record until
you buy it
right
um there
you know there there's
a trade-off you'll need to make in where
you're buying records from right you
could just go through go to like your
standard record store uh and like find a
perfectly decent record at probably a a
pretty decent price as well or you could
go to you know
more
more
eccentric record stores and maybe find
some hidden gems that are
preserved in like pristine condition
right so you'll need to you need to
somehow balance this ability to explore
in this ability to take risks with
actually achieving actually minimizing
your your final objectives
okay
so now let's talk about the formal model
so in the horror model there's a
universe u of elements uh which we just
referred to by numbers from 1 to n
for each element in that universe
we associate a random non-negative
integer which we call its weight
and we're going to be building sets in
these problems uh so we also have a
collection of the feasible sets which we
write as script f
and we have an objective function f
uh which takes as input all of the
weights of our selection set
um but you know just
we we write that as uh f of s sort of
like as an understood convention that
when you write ffs really like behind
the scenes uh the weights are having an
impact on the objective function
with all of that set up our goal is to
minimize the expected
objective value
final objective value
of our selection set
an important distinction we have to make
here also
is
adaptive versus non-adaptive
is the adaptive versus non-adaptive
setting here in the adaptive setting
you're building your selection set
one
element by element
and once you select an element and add
it to your set you get to see its random
weight and adapt your strategy based on
what you've seen so far
whereas in the non-adaptive setting you
you don't get to see anything until the
end so you're essentially choosing all
at once
okay
so with this formal model what does it
know well for maximization actually like
there are a lot of results for for um
for
adaptive uh
maximization probing problems right
there's this there's this huge bountiful
forest of results based on contention
resolution schemes profit inequalities
lps
so much relate sub modularity greedy
algorithms
everything under the sun
so what about minimization
um minimization
is more like a desert
uh
there's really not that much known
about minimization probing problems
not even for sort of
most basic
function that you can think of
it's the minimum weight element in your
selection
set okay so what is known what is known
actually for this minimum element
um objective function
uh we sort of wrote the problem
statement here on the left uh and we're
going to look specifically at the case
where
there's a knapsack constraint for our
set
right
most of most of what we know is from
how to probe for an extreme value a
paper by goel guha and munogala from
2010
and they give some really nice results
for the non-adaptive problem
specifically in the case where
the
random variables
are integers from 0 to m
right
they show a few things now the first
thing they show is
that it's actually np hard to
approximate
this
this problem without relaxing your
budget so you sort of have to relax your
budget to get anywhere
and once you relax that budget they also
give like a bike by criteria
approximation screen scheme that sort of
includes this log log in factor that
you'll see here
right and they do that using you know
submodularity and a greedy algorithm
plus like an lp to get like a good
initial condition
uh and at the end of that paper they
sort of left
obtaining adaptive approximations as a
challenging open problem
um
so what what about this problem actually
is so challenging you know why is it
answer
uh well one possible reason is that
there's sort of there's an asymmetry in
what we're asking for when we ask for
approximation algorithms for
maximization versus manipulation
and so
as a good example let's look at you know
taking a test
let's say this test is
out of 100 points
and assume like
the optimal you can get an expectation
is
99 points right the smartest kid in the
class is getting 99.
okay
so
if you get a two approximate if you get
a two approximation
and the maximization context that's
saying your expected score is better
than like about a 50
right whereas
in the minimization context
getting a two approximation
means that your expected number of
points loss
is less than or equal to two meaning
your expected score is like
greater than or equal to a 98
and so
uh
in in in certain contexts it seems as
though like when you ask for a
title
when you ask for an an approximation
algorithm in the minimization context
it's sort of it's a bigger deal
than in
in the maximization problem
context in a way we're sort of when we
talk about um
approximate immunization we're talking
about like
near
optimal maximization
okay
um so
that's all well and good
but
maybe we can still use things for
maximization to
solve our minimization problems
and so one common route that people use
to do this
is you know they they come up with an
algorithm they want to show that it's
close to the adaptive optimum
and so
the route they go through is to show
first that their algorithm is close to
the non-adaptive
their algorithms like expected values
close to the non-adaptive optimal value
right and they do that using
conventional approximation techniques
and then the second step is to show that
actually the non-adaptive optimum and
the adaptive optimum aren't that far
apart they show that the adaptivity gap
or the ratio between optima is small
okay and so
you know maybe one would hope
that we can do this in the minimization
context
um
okay so our hope is that you know
we have some algorithm
uh
say specifically for the min element
problem
um
and we show that it
and um goel gua and monogala have
already shown
that like their algorithm is close to
the non-adaptive optimum so if we can
just show that the non-adaptive optimum
is close to the adaptive optimum
then we'll have like uh adaptive
approximations and you know everyone can
clap and then go home
but the reality is actually the the
route doesn't look anything like this
we give an example that shows that uh
in general the non-adaptive optimum can
be arbitrarily worse than the adaptive
optimum
we give an example where the adaptivity
gap is arbitrarily large
adaptivity gives you an arbitrary amount
of power
which we we won't describe that example
now but
if you're interested you can check it
out in the paper
um
so now let's talk about like what we
were able to do in our paper
so for the min element objective
function with a knapsack constraint
where one should recall that the min
element objective function is just you
know f s is the min weight element it's
the weight of the min weight element in
f
um
for that setting we give it adaptive
approximation the first adaptive
approximation
um
with
our objective with our expected
objective value
being less than or equal to four times
the optimal and our cost being like
log log m
times the the budget
right and this closes an open problem
left by um
in how to broke for an extreme value
so once we've done this we also look at
a generalization which we call min
knapsack
where instead of just looking at the min
weight in s
we look at the sum of the smallest k
weights in s
right and there we also get an adaptive
approximation with a slightly worse
expected value
right
and with uh log squared k
in the um
sort of this resource augmentation
factor on this this uh
this cost factor
right we also in the paper in the
archive version at least we deal with
two other matrix-based variants
um
okay and so so how did we do this
well
the
root behind all of our results is this
new approach slash meta algorithm that's
based on adaptive probability
minimization
and i know what you're you're probably
saying right now it's like
probability minimization that sounds
harder than than expectation
minimization and in some cases like
you're probably right uh
but in some cases is actually tractable
so let me give you
uh
first some some intuition about like
what we're going to do or why why we
would even think this would work in the
first place
um
so
we start from just the this expectation
formula as the sum of these tail
probabilities
so if you take a single term for example
if you have the minimum
if you have this min element objective
function
uh with your knapsack constraint and you
look at like t equals to 2
right
that's like
minimizing that term is a problem in and
of itself
in particular we call that a threshold
problem because we're trying to get our
function
lower than some threshold we're trying
to
uh just to say it differently we're
trying to minimize the probability that
our final objective value is above some
threshold uh subject to our constraints
um
so this is sort of a there's a sort of
of an odd problem and it's not obvious
uh
like how you actually
approximate these threshold problems
but
that's what our key idea is actually if
you focus on getting adaptive
approximations to these social problems
then you know someone surprisingly
you'll be able to get some results
so let's let's go through an example
of a threshold problem
uh and
in this threshold problem
it's kind of it's nice to describe
things sort of
uh coin flip
and let me first explain what i mean by
that uh so you have this objective
function which is the probability that
the min
of all the elements you choose is
greater than two
so this
is equivalent to saying
uh
that with every element e
you you identify each element with a
coin
and it's a coin that's heads
if you
uh if the weight of that element is less
than or equal to two and it's tails if
you're above two
right
so then
uh in in that language
our objective function is just
minimizing the probability that we get
all tails when we're going through and
uh flipping coins
right
okay
uh
and the one thing you might realize
actually is that this problem even
though we've cast it in an adaptive
light even though we're looking for an
end approximation it's essentially a
non-adaptive problem right because as
soon as you get
a single heads
well your your
your run is over the game is over you've
won
and if you don't have a heads yet well
it's it's as if you you've never flipped
anything but you sort of
lost some budget and you lost some some
of the you lost some available elements
to choose from right and so this tells
us actually
that uh
like adaptivity gap for this problem is
one
which means we can reduce it to a
knapsack instance you know just through
some
some slight manipulation
uh
and that tells us that actually a greedy
alder
greedy algorithm is a one-two
approximation
uh gets like a perfect
it gives like the perfect probability
but it uses maybe twice the budget
okay so just rest assured it is possible
to solve these threshold problems uh
especially
particularly in the min element case you
know there's it's a very nice threshold
problem
okay
so now let's look at like realizing this
basic idea we had before so we have
these probability minimization problems
we have like
some we have a policy that we can run to
to
accomplish this minimization
um right how do we turn that into
a policy that minimizes an expectation
so just recall just go back to this
expectation as a sum of uh tail
probabilities
uh and we'll define
pi sub t as
the
policy that we're using to approximate
this structural problem and s of t as
its resultant set
so just the the most basic
uh most naive idea and one could do is
just say okay let's just run all of
these pi sub ts
and combine all of the s of ts
and that's going to be definitely better
than the expected
the expected optimum
um
the only bad thing about this is that
you also end up uh
you know probing like
you end up running like m of these
things where m is like possibly gigantic
so what we want to do is like maybe get
that cost factor
smaller even if it even if it results in
like a worse
um
like value approximation okay
right and so how do we do that how do we
go beyond the basic idea
uh well there are two like kind of clear
problems with our approach right now
uh the first problem is that the
uh
the thresholds that we're probing are
kind of redundant uh and let me explain
what i mean by that because uh the
summon the summons in like this tail sum
are monotone decreasing we don't
actually need to focus on minimizing
every single term because probably the
policies are going to be very similar
and like these these uh these in
probabilities are going to be like very
similar in value
um
so long as we're able to capture the
general trend then we'll be able to
approximate things well
and so what's our solution for this
uh it's just a
round up to the nearest power of 2.
if you do that
then the expected value of oct
or the expected value of any random
variable
is bounded from above by the sum which
only includes like
log m
uh probability terms and which is then
again bounded from above by two times
the original expectation
so that means that if we just focus on
minimizing these login terms then
somehow we'll we'll be good to go while
avoiding like a lot of the mess that we
had before
and so if we just use this idea directly
then this gives us
this gives us a cost factor of log of m
and gives us a value factor of 2 which
is worse than the one we had before but
you know only by a factor of two so so
it should still be fine
the other issue with our with our basic
idea is that we're we're not being
adaptive at all even though we have you
know access to adaptivity
so for example if we're just probing
things in a certain order and we probe
and we um
perform the
threshold test at uh at a threshold t
before we do t plus one
if we if we succeed at this threshold
test if we
get an objective function if we get an
objective value that's smaller than t
we're still going to go
like try to do all these threshold
problems that should we're trying to get
like an objective value that are that's
larger than t we're trying to get it
below a threshold that's larger than t
so like why why would we ever do that
so clearly we need a smarter way to
choose which thresholds to try
and you know what's the solution here
it's more involved i'm going to need
like a few slides to explain it
but the basic gist is that we're going
to search for the next threshold to try
okay
right so
the solution is adaptive binary search
and sort of the key idea here
is to take advantage
of the fact that you've gotten below a
threshold if you ever do
so let me just walk you through the
algorithm first and then i'll like sort
of go through an animation that shows
like how it would work
um so we're gonna define a threshold
test as you know
you you you're at a threshold
and you execute like
whatever um approximate policy we have
to to
minimize the probability that like tail
probability that we were looking at
before
right and we define a success if we
actually obtain an
objective value that's lower than
than that target threshold
right
so our algorithm is this
first you perform a threshold test at
the median
and if you succeed then you're cursed
with all the smaller thresholds and if
you fail you just recurse with the
larger thresholds
okay so let's just let's see that in
action the median here
is two to the four so we're going to
perform a threshold test there
we
set back and we see that the objective
value is actually less than or equal to
2 to the 4 is less than or equal to 16.
and so we're going to recurse on the
left
right so this is now
this um the brown orange region is like
the
available thresholds that we're looking
at
okay
so now we'll do this again the median
here is two to the two or four
right we've performed the threshold test
um we feel it so we go move to the right
and this sort of continues until you end
up with like you end up with nowhere
left to go no thresholds left to test
and at that point the algorithm
terminates
um
okay so so how do you prove that
something like this works well the key
idea is to
just analyze things based on an upper
bound
and that's
to analyze based on the highest
threshold that you failed
that you
failed to test that
[Music]
even though
even though it's technically possible
for you to get an objective value that's
smaller than the highest threshold you
feel that just you know through
happenstance uh by analyzing it this way
you can actually get a nice bound on
what's happening
okay
so that's sort of that's the meta
algorithm and that sort of you know
that's the root that's the core of uh of
our of our paper here
um so now let's look at the
generalization uh min knapsack and there
are a lot of interesting ideas here um
and we won't have time to get into all
of them but i invite you to read the
paper if if like any of this sounds
interesting
so it just is
that it's actually possible to do
something similar uh in this
generalization
um
in in terms of you know solving solving
special problems there's there's a
complicated reduction process actually
uh but what it leads you to is another
is is a generalization of this previous
coin problem we looked at before we had
some constraints and we wanted to
essentially maximize the probability
that we got at least one head
uh and while we were flipping coins
now what we want is to get at least j
heads
so
when j equals one you'll remember
uh the
solution the problem setting is
essentially uh non-adaptive uh but when
j is not equal to one this is this is
not true in general so don't
don't don't be deceived you actually
need to use adaptivity
to solve this
likely
you likely mean productivity to solve
this
so
how do you how do we go about solving
this our main idea is to reuse this um
greedy strat that we use when j is equal
to one but now with an augmented budget
now instead of just the just the normal
budget we also give it um
like enough money to buy like j extra
elements
so along with this main idea you have to
reduce this like general case where
where items can cost like
any amount from from one to b
uh to a case where the cost is actually
restricted
to being like b over j but that's
actually not too tricky with the the
simple bidding technique you can you can
you can get that
okay so
let me just talk about the
the min knapsack
uh
the the proof we have for like how to
how to handle this threshold problem
or why this you know this extended
greedy algorithm works
so what we do is make an inductive
argument
we argue by induction
uh in in this specific case we'll look
at j is equal to two so we're just we
want to get two heads at least
so in that case uh the optimal decision
tree or really any decision tree like uh
modulo like just
um
modulo things that don't affect the
final
their success probability of this
problem
um
their decision tree is going to look
like this they're going to choose like a
first coin to flip
if it comes up heads then they're going
to go to the right and go to like some
subtree
if it comes up tails then they'll go
down to another element
element two they're gonna flip
the the coin
associated with element two
uh and then if it comes up heads they're
gonna go down to this tree to
and so on and so forth
and the key thing to realize when you're
analyzing
this when you're trying to prove that
extended greedy is is good in this
context
is that in each of these subtrees
it basically looks like we're we're
doing a problem
like if you look at the system state
when you first move into that subtree
it looks like you're just starting a j
equals one problem
uh
and and sort of the rationale for that
is that like
you're flipping coins
and you need two coins
as soon as you get one or you're
flipping coins you need two heads as
soon as you get one heads
it's like
you're in this um
it's like you now you you now only need
one more heads uh you've gotten rid of
some budget you've gotten rid of some
elements that you can choose from but
everything is essentially
everything is essentially turned into
like a j equals one case
right and since we know that greedy
works in the j equals one case
uh we sort of know that like once we
landed those subtrees that we'll be good
to go as long as we're following the
greedy algorithm
right
and so once we've shown that like our
main goal is just to
uh
so now that we've shown that we know
that like the main thing that determines
whether a policy is good is like how
quickly it gets its first heads
right and actually
the greedy algorithm optimizes for this
like if you choose according to the
heuristic that that we've shown
um
and specifically if we give
greedy
uh in like a little bit of extra budget
to get a head start versus every other
policy then that's enough to show that
it actually uh in in in some way like
stochastically dominates all other
feasible policies
which i think is it's a pretty cool
result
okay um
and so that's i think all the time time
we have for like technical stuff today
um
so just as a conclusion first let me
recap stuff
uh
the beginning is not much known for
minimization probing problems
but in this work we give a new approach
based on what we call threshold problems
which are adaptive probability
minimization problems
um we also give bi-criteria
approximations for a few threshold
problems which end up you know when
combining with this new approach they
they close
an open problem of goel gua and nagala
from how to broke for an extreme value
[Music]
right
open problems from this work are
adaptive hardness
so
in how to pro for an extreme value they
show that
this non-adaptive version of the problem
is np hard to approximate without
relaxing the budget but essentially
nothing is known about the adaptive case
and it's it's
it's not even
clear like how to start things how to
start things off given like how
different um
uh adaptive
optimization is to non-adaptive
optimization
um
another open problem uh is you know
in our
uh like cost factor there's like a log
log in there
and there's also a log log m in
uh
how to in the how to probe for an
extreme value cost factor and so one
question is like is that log log m
actually like fundamental like is it
possible to get lower than that or is
there something
uh
is there some core aspect of the problem
that limits us to
log log n
and another natural open problem is
as it possibly get like an approximation
scheme here instead of just these you
know these fixed
these fixed
factor
approximation results that we derive in
our paper
okay
and so
just some takeaways
of the talk in the paper
is that actually the greedy algorithm
can have much stronger properties
than you
[Music]
then you initially make use of when you
like set up your heuristic like
uh
i think there are a lot of aspects of
greedy algorithms that we sort of take
for granted
that we don't always use to their
fullest extent
and this is an example of if you do use
those properties
just like a little bit more then you can
actually get some very very strong
results
and then besides that uh
iterative goal setting works and that's
kind of what our
meta algorithm does it does some
iterative goal setting
and so that's useful in a personal
context as well as
an algorithmic context
okay so this is the final thing uh
thanks for listening uh if you enjoyed
the talk or you're interested in uh
anything here feel free to email me and
check out the paper on archive and also
published
in this
current proceedings of itcs
and thanks for all of the funding
sources we have
nsf uh the gym fellowship and the gates
millennium scholars program
thanks for listening everyone
and i'll see you at the conference